when I wrote the book I was primarily
focused on the business situation
because i was looking at how companies
can grow and prosper and it seemed that
empathy was the biggest differentiator
but you know what I've been most
surprised about is how much empathy is
become a a larger trend something that
is being focused on at the highest
levels of government even Barack Obama
has become our chief empathy officer for
the country and I've it's just been
amazing to see when he was at the
Saddleback ranch last year and and Rick
Warren asked him why do you want to be
President the number one reason he gave
was because his grandmother had taught
him the value of empathy and he felt
that that needed to be brought back to
government and to America and and when
he was asked to choose a Supreme Court
nominee Obama said that he was looking
for someone who first and foremost had a
sense of empathy and this is a big deal
people kind of flipped out on both sides
of the aisle I what does he mean by
empathy whatever is that be a good thing
is it a bad thing are you people on the
right saying that oh by empathy he means
we want someone who's a pushover and
that's a sign of what's wrong with this
country it seems like empathy has gotten
a bad rap over the last 50 years in
America we've kind of confused it with
being touchy-feely or soft minded when
what it really means is just the
intuitive ability to connect with other
people and Barack gets that but I think
he's leading us to a different place
it's a sign of Obama's ability to
connect with people that we don't call
him President Obama we call him Barack
the people i know refer to him by his
first name like he's one of us
you